Elite Runners set the fastest times
but it's ordinary people who often bring
the most remarkable stories
Anusha shuri spent five years in an
Iranian jail accused of spying if you
are imprisoned unjustly
and you have got a long sentence in
front of you you have to do something to
fight insanity
and that is what I did I took running as
a way of fighting inside
for some people the distance traveled to
get past the Finish Line has been more
than 26.2 miles the crowd support the
costumes it was amazed amazing The
Amazing weather the landmarks that you
went by running over Tower Bridge was
incredible
some 40 000 people took part in today's
Marathon including some famous faces
that last 10 kilometers was hell it was
I was just a mental battle I kept just
saying you know one foot in front of the
other I was I was counting I was
thinking of my family I was I was just
trying everything to keep going Chris
Finnell has been doing this every year
since 1981. it's a much much bigger race
now far more women running it's almost
50 50. Charities are a huge part of this
race so that's that's the thing that
that's morphed and this this race 2022
is good because the conditions are so
great and I think it's a genuine return
to normality the pandemic's impact on
the marathon has seen it pushed back to
the Autumn now for three years running
but this is the last year that it will
be held in October with next year's
Marathon set to return to its usual
Springtime slots the ballot for places
in next year's race is set to close on
Friday Sadia Chaudhary Sky News at the
London Marathon